make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we're getting back into heroes
in crisis in part seven and this is one
of the things I love a lot about the
hero's in crisis story is this more of
like a philosophical story right and and
for some people that doesn't really do
it for me right like for some people
they like action-packed stories like
fighting and in the traditional comic
book story kind of kind of tale but the
way this is done by Tom King it's really
more of like a philosophical look at
heroes right like it kind of removes the
action to remain has some in there but
it's more of just the philosophical look
at things and a lot of this really this
the like the biggest part of this story
focuses on Wally West because of reality
like Wally West is the character that I
think a lot of people are that were at
least at the outset of DC rebirth the
most intrigued in and even during the
events of new 52 right like flashpoint
happened new 52 kicked off and then
Barry Allen was armed sorry Wally West
was nowhere to be found
and everybody wanted to know where like
classic Wally West went we got a
rebooted version of his character but
some fans reject that other fans
embraced it and the result was that on
the whole people were just curious where
the red-haired Wally west wind so when
he came back then it was suddenly like
okay well then how do we make this work
and that's really been like the whole
nature of his character and even up
until now even through like Joshua
Williamson's flash run all the way up
until now this really kind of seems to
be the point where it focuses the most
on like the experience of Wally after
essentially having come back now there
are a couple of things that go on in
here there is Booster Gold there is
Harley it's not really essential I don't
think it may be that later on it is and
if it is then what kind of come back to
it but for the most part a lot of this
focus is on Batman Barry Allen and then
of course Wally West and initially this
kind of picks up with like Wally West's
introduction into sanctuary the idea
that he's really kind of hopeful here
and that's the cool thing about this is
that you can sort of see this transition
as the story goes on you see this kind
of transition from with Wally West where
he's initially very hopeful and he's
very optimistic in terms of the purpose
of sanctuary conserve right because the
idea of sanctuary was to was supposed to
be a place of respite a place where like
people could go where characters could
go it kind of spilled their deepest
darkest secrets or in some form or
fashion offer a revelation or the very
least cope with the things that caused
them harm in order to find some measure
of peace but it's basically Wally just
kind of coming to coming to terms with
the fact that he's he's here and he's
sort of celebrating the fact that he can
kind of move past all the struggle and
strife that he's endured again we'll
talk about that here in a second but one
of the cool things about this is that
what it does it it kind it kind of
transitions over to Barry Allen and
Batman now remember when it comes to
Batman and Barry Allen Barry Allen is
really kind of on a wharf
because of the fact that Wally West died
that's really kind of why he's playing
the role that he is in heroes in crisis
that you literally had Booster Gold who
showed up and kind of spilled the beans
that that Wally West died and then
buried has kind of lost his mind right
and then of course Batman's
investigating because it's Batman and so
from here it jumps back in to Wally West
again now with Wally West the cool thing
here is that as he starts to go through
this he starts talking about progress
and he starts talking about all these
things that are important to him Linda
iris joy all these individuals but the
problem is that they're all gone and as
you look through this you kind of
noticed like this this difference is
this kind of shift it's not a huge shift
but it's kind of shift he's not as
optimistic anymore he's not as hopeful
anymore it's only a second week but he's
not as hopeful anymore as time passes he
seems to lose more and more hope but the
whole base is behind us is the fact that
everything he knows is gone right like
that's the whole thing behind Wally
imagine for example that like you woke
up tomorrow and like none of your family
knew who you were everything you know
everything of value to you has vanished
no one knows who you are now that's the
best thing is you that Wally West is it
now conventional wisdom would say well
then just tell them just walk up there
and just tell them but how do you tell
them that how do you walk up to a person
who as far as they're aware has never
met you has no idea who you are and say
we had a family together they're gonna
think you're crazy
not only that from the perspective of
Wally West one of the things to bear in
mind is he's a tried and true hero and
so when that's the case he kind of has
to ask himself the question is it really
better off for Linda Park to know the
history between herself and Wally
there's no guarantee that she'll do the
same thing iris West did when when Barry
basically revealed everything to Irish I
said hey we were supposed to be together
and when basically iris learned
everything about Wally that hey like I'm
your long-lost nephew or an Indian
basically like I'm inserting the Speed
Force unless there's no guarantee that
Linda would react the same way as iris
where iris embraced Wally Linda could
rebuke him would Wally be able to
withstand that and would it be better
off for Linda or is it better to just
kind of leave her be and so from here
again it kind of shifts back to Batman
and to Barry and they're literally
running through like all the safe houses
that that Booster Gold and that Ted Kord
Blue Beetle usually stay at and it's
kind of a funny little exchange here
like Batman's like hey man you could
just use the bat radio like is it like
running all over the place and then
running back every time we visit
somewhere we run to Australia run back
run to Berlin run back you can just use
the bat radio and tell me you don't
haven't found anything and Barry's like
yeah but like I'm faster than the bat
radio and Batman's like well I mean I
mean I'm not so sure about that but
guess who the son of the right
frequencies I could be wrong for the
first time that I'm aware of in DC
Comics Batman admits that he could be
wrong but you know kind of going into
Wally West getting into a second week
here this is really really cool because
what it does is it kind of refreshes you
know Bob I guess really Wally's kind of
origin story it's basically explaining
everything about his life and it's kind
of like hey look I was a hero since I
was a teenager I modeled myself after
Barry Allen Barry Allen died and I
became the new flash but the cool thing
about this is Tom King kind of relies on
us as the reader to sort of know these
little these little tidbits of what kind
of goes on behind the scenes right like
you had Barry Allen as as the flash you
ran all the way up until crisis on
Infinite Earths and Wally West was kid
flash and then Barry Allen died during
crisis on Infinite Earths or at least he
was believed he died and then during the
events of Final Crisis it was revealed
that he was stuck in the Speed Force but
for all intents and purposes post-crisis
Barry was dead and so during that time
Wally West stepped into the role of
becoming the new flash and in the early
stories under Mike Barron it was all
about Wally West basically being under
the shadow of Barry can he ever truly be
as good as Barry could he ever really be
the great kind of flash superhero that
Barry Allen was causally comparing
himself to Barry Allen it wasn't until
Mike Barron left the title and Mark Waid
took over it suddenly it turned into
okay let's start focusing on the
expansion of Wally it was a natural
progression
once Wally had kind of stepped into his
role as being the flash accepted his
role as a hero then we started getting
stories like terminal velocity we
started getting stories like the return
of Barry Allen which was the basically
post-crisis origin for eobard thawne the
reverse-flash
we started getting like all these
different these different expansions on
the nature of Wally and then him growing
I guess him kind of moving on further
marrying Linda Park who I think was a
reporter at the time eventually having
giant iris you know being involved in
Infinite Crisis Barry Allen actually
coming back you know during like the the
original flash rebirth event it's kind
of cool with all these little things but
Tom King kind of relies on this it's one
of the reasons why it's sort of a little
bit of a goodie here is because for
somebody who's new is okay cool it's
this him doing his origin for those who
have been part of the flash mythos for a
long time they kind of look at this and
saying okay I understand where he's
coming from because like here are all
the things that Wally West has been
through over the course of his life as a
hero and that's why it's interesting
because what this does is it kind of
really allows us to sort of expand and
build on his character and like the
deficits of struggle and strife that
he's been through all this time and so
when this happens when suddenly like
after all the things that he's endured
all the laws that he's in do err to in
turn come back from the Speed Force and
find out that no
knows who he is except for Barry and the
Titans with his wife Rosa novias and his
kids are missing it's a crushing
experience and so as he goes through
here one of the things I want kind of do
is I want to jump back to the very very
beginning of the story because what this
did is it kind of gave us this poem that
Wally was sort of musing over and what
he says is that in the beginning when he
and Linda Park first got married she
read this poem off to him it was kind of
like her vow to him and watch what he
says is that this poem that she read was
really more about like death and rebirth
it was about sometimes we lose things
but we can always get those things back
it's only how hard it is that we
basically work for it and it's kind of
cool because what he says is is like you
know nark adhere to that we talked about
in the last video kind of explained it
to him he only said that it's all about
creation it's all about making things
you know it's not necessarily about
literally making things but about how
love makes things that essentially it
was really kind of a poem of hope that
that Wally West still has the chance to
speak to Linda Park he still had the
chance to get her back and by virtue of
doing that tracking down and then of
course getting his kids but at the same
time that he does this he basically
snaps his fingers creates a crack of
lightning and basically like brings back
poison ivy he essentially resurrect her
from the dead now the cool thing about
this this is one of the important
elements to remember is that Tom Keyes
not pulling this out of his backside
right like on the surface it would be
easy to assume that when it comes to
poison ivy remember she's part of the
green she's basically pardon she's she's
a plant elemental is really what she is
that was one of the things that was
established about her through Swamp
Thing but you had you had like Swamp
Thing so you had the red which is
people's ability to basically kind of
commune with the animal animal side of
the world more or less or I guess the
animal side of the universe because they
can kind of expand that beyond just the
or just the planet Earth but then
there's also the rot which is basically
everything dead more or less and then
there's the green which is plant life
and so walkways and I have your physical
form would die her spiritual essence
would essentially become part of the
green which means at any point she can
be brought back and that's exactly what
what Wally does he resurrects her from
the dead and it's kind of a cool thing
because initially we thought that that
poison ivy was going to be gone forever
but Tom P explicitly told us in the
beginning of heroes in crisis on Twitter
and various forms of social media
they're not gonna stay dead forever
there's no reason they would that the
story's designed to be self contained is
designed to be a set of events to take
place and that effectively end with
things kind of being returned to the
status quo and that's why it's so cool
is because for everything we see here
while there is the caveat that
essentially none of it really seems to
matter there's also the benefit that at
the end of it all there could be after
if
there could be things that kind of
continue on from the events of heroes in
crisis but that's kind of where this big
revelation comes from is because while
Wally
is talking to poison ivy what he says is
I hurt you I was supposed to help you
and I didn't I was supposed to be a hero
and I didn't at a time when you needed
me I basically let you die and the
reason why was because I wasn't really
being a hero and I apologize for that
because you're gonna have to see what
comes next and when she says what she
says my death you're going to have to
watch me die and that's the crazy thing
because essentially Wally West is in the
present watching himself die presumably
coming from the future or the past we
don't know but would that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comment
explain make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the Rob for if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]